mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
a convex quadrilateral has diagonals
that are perpendicular to each other
if three consecutive sides have lengths
of 3 2 and 1
what is the length of the fourth side
i thank anas for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
let's label some of the lengths in this
diagram we have w x y and z
consider this right triangle
by the goku theorem we have w squared
plus x squared is equal to three squared
in this right triangle we have x squared
plus y squared is equal to two squared
then in this right triangle we have y
squared plus z squared is equal to 1
squared
we want to calculate the hypotenuse of
this right triangle
to do that we'll subtract the second
equation and then add the third equation
in doing so we will cancel out the x
squared and y squared terms we're left
with w squared plus z squared is equal
to three squared minus two squared plus
one squared this means w squared plus z
squared is equal to six
the hypotenuse will be equal to the
square root of this
therefore we have the square root of w
squared plus z squared is equal to the
square root of six and that's the answer
to this problem
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you